matricule 96 0 38 653 cette année un
combinat hambourg particulier alors que
d'autres à sona j'avais gisent le
promets
des poubelles
ma femme a le rôle du petit déjeuner moi
j'ai le rôle du réveil rhône est
partagée et il se lève il faut le réveil
une fois je suis du soleil il faut un
certain temps donc c'est moi qui assure
après la ponctuation de son réveil
donc il a eu du mal à se réveiller mais
après ça s'est bien passé huit heures la
faute à la même enseigne
une telle plus mature je l'aï dit les du
qg je m'inscris
j'ai dit tout à l'heure et mais ce
raisonnable une position passion raison
on verra plus avoir de préférence social
ça mais n'aura pas le loisir de
disserter sur ces deux thèmes préférés
les sujets du jour y at il des vérités
définitives et une réflexion sur les
imperfections du langage au bout de ces
trois heures ça mêleront sa copie plutôt
satisfait
ce sujet c'était il ya t'il est
nécessairement des imperfections dans le
langage donc j'ai parlé en gros ap ap /
de langage humain les différents
problèmes pouvait y avoir et que est ce
que pour nous c'est obligatoire d'avoir
un langage à part fait et ce qu'il
existait un langage parfait enfin tous
ces problèmes
la note alors ça pour voir
on verra le 4 juillet